belle a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj finalmente siamo
tanti sud e scender schiera il gioco
quello della pc avevo detto che sto
gioco sarebbe stato fighissimo è già un
gioco figo ma sarebbe stato ancora più
figo se avessero messo la possibilità di
fare livelli più estremi e la tenne che
non c'erano so io scemo e sto gioco tipo
minecraft decisioni sid e quindi ho
scaricato un paio di codici dei livelli
figli allora io non ho ancora fatto
neanche uno
la madonna solo ho solo visto il codice
non ne ho fatto mezzo registrato subito
mi sono messo lì eletto non deve
provarlo
ora mi son messo a registrare
immediatamente regalo state scoprendo
con me ma ce ne elicottero come facciano
finire tranciato la le pale dove va bene
via
ok forse la partenza non è delle
migliori devo stare dritto immagina devo
stare dritto bene è abbastanza ripida la
faccenda qua credo è poi non lo so
grazie a dio so ciò che come minecraft
quindi è infinito a livello di di
livelli infimi porca vacca aiuto 130
morti è la madonna mi sono andato a
schiantare va bene è proprio per un
check point per la madonna
raga aiuto aiuto e si vabbè ciarletta
tutto rosso non è anche visto cosa ho
sbattuto d'accordo mi sa che mi sono
fatto un po male però vabbè c'è stato
momento in cui se variati a 130 prima di
tornare a 130 fermi tutti è difficile lo
giuro è difficilissimo no vabbè ma è
impossibile tenere la è veramente
impossibile madonna chi è male ma in
autostrada rega
guarda lo guardavo vecchia che salto
ecco che no però atterrato fortissimo
cavolo ci ho creduto una domanda ma se
vado qua a destra che succede
no per dire ok c'è della roba un po
strana pro cav h non mi sono fatto male
aiuto la casetta chi l'ha vista da dove
uscita frena un po freno frena frena
frena bravo così esattamente così
perfetto ho parcheggiato piano o amen
amen una sega vabbè ci arriva lo stesso
guardali che bravo salve vorrei dei
biglietti per la funivia grazie
piano piano magagna ok adesso spiegami
come faccio ad arrivarle ma io posso
passare anche in mezzo qua si merita
detto scotti ai vai vai vai vai vai ma
eccolo
ce l'ho fatta è un miracolo per me è
veramente un miracolo si sta roba
fammi vedere cos'è questa roba qua è più
sera
lo capisco cosa sono sti cosi prova
veglie sticazzi nuovo ruolo dico io mi
sa che ti sei fatto male la vinci la
perdiamo è anche tutto il resto del
corpo è nata però questo è il sil deve
cambiamo un numero giusto per capire
cosa cambia per me è un po diverso cosa
succede
ho cambiato leggermente il sito è
cambiata leggermente tutta la mappa va
bene aiuto madonna viola no perché ma
allora allora zitti mi appare simbolo in
basso a sinistra e non mi fa più
atterrare e non capisco come come dovrei
riuscire ad atterrare o che hanno
atterrato ma perché ora kcal h sono
scarso ok quest'onda non sbaglia
il percorso è un altro in teoria prova
bene è un po di fisioterapia e tutto a
posto zio madonna aveva ben fatto le
provate ho fatto poi ho fatto cagare ma
può cambiare altri tre numeri sempre
sempre in inverno è però stavolta la
rampa cielo subito ragazzi
bello bello è piaciuto questo il resto
un po meno però però sono sul percorso
piano vai piano per l'amore di gesù e di
maria
piano piano
no no no la città devo fare quando
saltare non salta fin lì già sei scemo
ok l'ho preso di lato di lato di lato ok
ero quasi arrivato ma va bene lo stesso
dai sù sù o bene sono arrivato sul
percorso non chiedetemi come va va bene
così non è vero sono scemo da quanto
difficile no per rifarlo daccapo porca
eva ma non ci arriverò mai la sua
impossibile è impossibile
pensi di essere albaro cosa mi fanno
notare dalla regia che qua cioè una
funivia schiantata quanto manca grosso
gioco perfetto
non è vero moderna perfetto o nicchia
una vita per fare sta roba è
difficilissimo sto livello ve lo giuro
e va bene gli olo jolo gli olo e alla
fine quella vaffan
ti prego non l'albero porca vacca
l'albero l'albero dai tua madre in
tronco
cioè io ero arrivato fino alla fine non
l'albero ha generato un altro livello
ragazzi vediamo che esce fuori il per
ora la madonna sempre più ripida la
partenza ecco appunto
grazie pian piano piano piano bay piano
gli apostoli piano
no no non cadere perché casi perché se
immuni completi con rosette cosa c'è ke
problemi china non riusciva a stare in
piedi sulla bici alle volte cade da solo
cioè non capisco stai per era tanto
difficile ok questo sembra fattibile
raga mi chiamo l'ho detto madonna che
botta ho dato porca vacca
ero così ho dato una botta incredibile
di culo al co alla funivia
adesso no ok bene così perfetto questa
volta buona questa volta buona
questa è la volta dove dall'altra sei
scemo poi puoi cadere in piedi grazie
perfetto ora frena dove il traguardo che
in teoria ci sono abbastanza vicino in
teoria
vela no non cadere non cadere ma non sai
stare in bici maledizione allora piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano per
favore piano ok
dov'è il traguardo visto che ho solo più
una vita traguardo ora che eccolo e ce
la fa chi credi ci ha messo una vita a
un livello l'ho finito bene se sta roba
è una rampa cosa ho fatto un fenomeno la
patata cielo ai miei piedi miglior biker
della storia orale e poi ha il mio
stesso fisico sto viper identico sembra
veramente io col casco attenzione che
sbaglio e ce la sto facendo senza morire
neanche una volta
non sono io che sto giocando in realtà
anzi guarda faccio che non ci vado
neanche vado a destra fammi vedere di
cosa sei capace dio
minchia stavo scherzando la madonna
mi sa che mi sono fatto male trovo
questo stiamo l'estero dove stiamo
partendo qua non c'è la pista per c'è la
pista la siete scemi ma è la presiede
drogati tutti non c'è la pista ma anche
alla pista questo livello vabbè mezzo
agli alberi ragazzi rischio di morire da
un secondo all'altro ma vabbè ecco
appunto l'ultimo livello ragazzi prova a
generarlo che non è in montagna ma è
nella foresta
almeno quello sono un sacco di altri
biomi che non ho provato per opera oggi
facciamo questo come ultimo c'è del
tempo cattivo
sembra di stare nel sottosopra di
strange things aiuto ma dov'è la pista o
ragazzi perdo le piste io c'è un
problema orca vacca che male eccola però
la pista l'ho trovata quindi queste più
ad ostacoli in italia che ha tratto la
difficilissimo come te io devo riuscire
a sopravvivere a sta roba
ma vi rendete conto di quanto può essere
difficile c'è male siete stata vabbè ei
bravo
guardali guardali con l'ultima vita
fenomeno si è dato fenomeno all'ultima
vita è un fenomeno
è bravo vedevo arrivare a cava ca c'è un
traguardo prima o poi ok
eccolo
signori numero uno oggi ho giocato
benissimo non so perché all'inizio fatto
cagare però permetteteci a una montagna
così io concludo che questo episodio di
the scender se ci sono anche altri biomi
che non vi ho fatto vedere ma magari nel
prossimo episodio vi farò vedere
per adesso va bene così come al solito
ragazzuoli sei video è piaciuto lasciato
mente mi piace anche vari soci dato
notizia le quali si chiede e noi ci
vediamo all'opera servito bene così
[Musica]